[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to our
special look at Hollywood beauty and how
you can get it all right let's get
started with the American actress who's
about to become British royalty the one
and only Megan Marco yeah just 50 more
days until her big day with Prince Harry
and we know she's going to look
breathtaking because we've been tracking
Megan's beauty evolution Megan selfie
okay she's becoming one of the most
famous women in the world and her style
has come a long way since she was a
briefcase model on Deal or No Deal for
Megan
[Applause]
these days her makeup is more natural
and she's dressing in a conservative
manner but still showing personal Flair
we love these burnt orange Jimmy Choo
heels the California girl has always
been health-conscious Megan ax is a
complete fitness fanatic she loves to
run laps around Kensington Gardens which
is just outside Kensington Palace I'm
told that she is a fan of a private
member's Club that do intensive fitness
training classes in hairy life loss and
love Katie Nichol rates that Megan's
healthy influence has rubbed off on
Harry he likes to start his day with a
green juice now just like Megan and his
friends will find this very amusing
you'll often see him visiting the gym
and he's given up his beloved marlboro
lights or at least he's smoking less and
he's drinking less I've learned blessed
with all out of hair
oh we know whether she wears it down and
loose or tucked into a messy bun Megan's
hair has made headlines her long flowing
style is similar to what her character
Rachel Zane wears on suits we've gotten
this Rachel sort of quintessential very
polished blowout gown so in real life I
like to sort of have a lot more texture
and play with it for her glowing
complexion megan visits london's skin
guru Niccolo Joss her specialty a deep
face massage - really good to give you
that high cheekbone
and when it's time for girls night out
with her friends the future royal drops
by the brown cow pub owned by a friend
of Harry's some of the house favorites a
killer burger Bloody Marys and chocolate
mousse we'll have what they're having
chocolate mousse nah I'm not before your
big day she's got to be on wedding bod
operation wedding that man likes her
curves and edges hi - okay I'm too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]